good evening everyone
welcome to Vapor District Council
I am councilor Catherine Grandin
chairman of beaver District Council and
I will be chairing the meeting today
may I first of all remind you all of
some domestic Arrangements
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs
cold water is also available in the
breakout area outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound please
leave the meeting room by following the
fire exit signs and meet on Ipswich Town
Football Club training pitch
do not re-enter the building until
you're told it is safe to do so
please switch off all mobile phones and
turn them to silent
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of this milk meeting will be
filmed except where there are
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consented to being filmed by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting and
or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May recalled film photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and press are not lawfully
excluded
I'll now move on to the agenda
[Applause]
item one apologies for absence
thank you chair we have apologies for
abstinence from councilor Ayers
councilor Gould councilor Jameson
councilor Mabry and councilor Newman
thank you item two Declarations of
Interest by councilors aren't only
Declarations of Interest
thank you no no declarations
item three
BC
2234 to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on 22nd November 2022 for
accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
thank you can I have a proposer please
thank you Adrian Osborne
can I have a second Earth please
thank you Bryn Huron
we're going to do this by a show of
hands so can I have a show of hands for
all those who are in favor please
please that's Curry thank you
item four paper BC 22 35
announcements from the chairman and
leader
I refer you to paper bc22 35 for noting
and I just wanted to say
um thank you to those people who have
bought tickets for my event this
Saturday and thank you to all of those
who have kindly donated today
um for my Posh raffle
um I'm very grateful to you all for your
support thank you
um and I think it's a gonna be a good
evening on Saturday I look forward to
seeing those who are coming thank you
and I'd now like to ask um
Council award to make his announcements
thank you chairman haven't got much to
uh to say this evening just a couple of
things firstly you'll all probably have
heard by now that our second bid for 5.8
million pounds from the leveling up fund
for the Hamilton Road Site regeneration
and Sudbury Town Center transport
schemes failed indeed there was nothing
at all for Suffolk in this current
leveling up fund round it is hugely
disappointing especially considering it
had a medium to high benefits cost ratio
on monetary value in addition to other
non-monetorized benefits
it has made a complex and difficult
project very uncertain and we'll be
talking to Suffolk County Council about
our options
you'll all probably be aware by now that
as a result of last year's elections act
fertile ID will be required for those
voting in person and the capital
elections in May
a range of existing documents are
acceptable as valid photo identification
and most people will have at least one
of these but those who don't will have
to obtain a virtual Authority
certificate
we now have an information page on our
website where we have included a link to
the application page on the gov.uk
website as well as information about how
a paper application can be made
and this only applies to voting at a
polling station there is no change to
the postal voting process
we'll be embarking on a comprehensive
publicity campaign over the next few
weeks and we will include more details
in next month's town and Parish
briefings
it'll be good if everyone could
publicize this at why dealing as often
as possible over the next few weeks so
that no one is denied a vote on May the
4th thank you
thank you Council Ward
item five oh
councilor Busby yeah sorry chair with
the minutes
um does it matters are arising from
those minutes uh well can I just make an
apology uh the question that was put to
me by Brian Riley about the increase in
Auditors fees the second question uh was
I promise to get back to him
unfortunately I haven't done that what I
can explain to him now is that the
increase was largely due to extra
demands made by the government on the
actual Auditors in terms of our fixed
assets
thank you councilor Busby
we'll now move back to the agenda
item five
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with Council procedure rules
thank you chair none received
item six questions by the public in
accordance with Council procedure rules
thank you chair none received
seven questions by counselors in
accordance with Council proceed
none receive chair
thank you
item 8 paper BC 22 36
overview scrutiny committee report
I would like to invite councilor Hinton
to introduce his report councilor Hinton
[Music]
first thing I would like to do is to
apologize for
this report being four and a bit pages
long well I did say when I was made
chairman of overview and scrutiny I
wanted to see all reports as two sides
of A4 only I will get there eventually I
hope
uh I'm not proposing to say very much
about the report it's all there in front
of you I I would just like to say that I
did and also have to join this period
approve a contract that was taken
without competitive tendering which was
for fire and smoke alarms in our Council
properties to comply with the
legislation uh which I was obviously
quite happy to to approve so that we
didn't then have to call it in as a
I would also just like to draw attention
to the scrutiny and cabinet protocol
it is mentioned on page 19 of your
papers
I would say this is common sense but as
I said to a colleague earlier on today
as Mark Twain said
you can hardly call it common sense
there was not enough of it around to be
called common this is very logical let's
use that word instead and it links up
the committee members with cabinet and
officers to make sure that they're all
working together for the for the benefit
of the council
and I'm quite happy to take any
questions
thank you are there any questions to
counselor Hinton
fine if there are no questions we'll
move on to the next item on the agenda
item nine to receive reports from
cabinet members
I would like to invite councilman Clarin
to introduce her report
paper cmu1
Cabinet member for committee communities
and well-being councilman Khan thank you
thank you madam chairman
um I welcome this opportunity to present
this update as cabinet in order for
communities and wellbeing
I must confess that as a ward member my
understanding of the common communities
and well-being activities was very
limited
the member briefings I attended failed
to give me an insight into the diversity
and sheer hard work that is undertaken
by 18 people
to achieve amazing in-house and
multi-organizational work on behalf of
baber District Council
the work they are undertaken affects you
your family your neighbors your parishes
and your wards
over the past few months I have worked
very hard to understand the motivation
and direction of our three locality
teams which were implemented last year
yellow blue and green
I have met with various groups and
individuals and found out how these
teams action and ideas are impacting
those people who are in need
of course the community's teams have not
the Manpower or the financial resources
to work alone they work with and
coordinate the efforts of Health the
voluntary sector the private sector the
police
other directorates within verbra
District Council under the councils
I have met and spoken with people whose
lives have been and are being impacted
by this amazing partnership
if you want to hear more examples will
be shared at the member briefing on the
31st of January
you have before you are very
comprehensive report and appendices
details of Pastor Gene sorry details of
past achievements and plans for the four
key functions of our teams which are
Community safety which includes
anti-social behavior and safeguarding
health and well-being Community
Development grants Leisure Sport and
active participation
these underpin the council's corporate
plan through the strategies that reflect
those functions however
we live in a real world
and in that real world came crashing
into our plans and strategies with the
pandemic hybrid working and a cost of
living crisis which not only affected
our residents but our staff
and also Ward members the five-point
cost of living plan was developed and is
now constantly been updated as new and
local National challenges present
themselves on a regular basis
but there has been some revising of the
initial five objectives and you will see
those in due course
but the Baseline was to coordinate
government support
to exercise discretion when providing
welfare sport support and advice
to maximize partnership working and
establish systems to provide targeted
support in localities
to maintain good health
and to enable people to access food and
nutrition
I would like to thank interim director
di Robinson corporate manager Vicki
Mosley and the three assistant managers
and their teams who have patiently dealt
with my questions over the past few
months and supplied me with endless
invitations to participate and
experience the real world of Hands-On
support
I would also like to thank the comms
team especially Jake foxford who
promotes and publicizes the good work of
the community's directorate
in conclusion members I have two
requests
first
please spend your locality budget before
the closing date
there are a lot there is still a lot of
money unspent the deadline is the 25th
of February
and the second
request
if you want to learn more about the real
bit different we are making
in our communities
there is a member briefing at the end of
the month on the 31st of January and we
welcome all members
some chairman I recommend that this
report be for noting only thank you
thank you Council McLaren are there any
questions for Council McLaren
councilor Hinton
not too complicated to one but uh just
two
um a stage one of my uh concerns and
that is on page 23 when you talk about
each of the functions underpins the
council's corporate plan through the
delivery of the following strategies or
plans at the bottom Western Suffolk
Community safety partnership action plan
we don't have access and that comes
before doing scrutiny that's why I know
about it but we don't have anything for
the eastern part of the district and we
know that there's a very good liaison
Parish liaison meeting run by former
councilor Trump ward in the east of the
district but there's no formal
Baba representation on that and it would
be nice if we could have some sort of
liaison with that group on baber to
complete the
to councilor Hinton well that wasn't
complicated but I can't actually give
you an answer right now unfortunately
can we get I will in discussion with the
director and the corporate manager we
will get back to you in due course thank
you very much
uh councilor Davis wanted to say
something
yeah thank you um I'm the chairman of
the Western Community safety partnership
and the Western Safety Community
Partnership despite its name covers the
whole of the district
from Haverhill to shortly in fact
including Grantham and East burgle so
the action plan for the Western Civic
Community Partnership is actually that
covers Us East
safety partnership covers felixstowe and
Bay City East of Ipswich including
Ipswich
councilor Lindsay
thank you chair just a quick one I think
my award seems to be written out of the
record uh Northwest cosford in the
communities offices locality areas
unless I've missed it I can't see uh
let's see it in there so I hope I've got
a locality officer and it's just a
oversights
can I just respond to you
the the corporate manager that will get
back to you regarding that and we're
sorry for the oversight
okay
thank you um just looking for some
reassurance from the cabinet member if
possible
uh I note and appreciate that evercroft
Leisure do a wonderful
service for us in our community
but there was a recent report published
up to 30 40 of leisure centers could
actually go out of business due to the
increased utility costs that they're um
that aluminum for them for them is there
any reassurance that she can give that
baby will continue to support at the
cross Leisure as we did during the
pandemic
so I will answer very briefly and then
if
the interim director would like to
confirm what I have to say I am I we
have recently done a review
I'm very satisfied with the relationship
we have with Abby crop Leisure and
um
we uh meet we meet with them on a
quarterly basis and so there is no fear
at the moment of any and toward
changes in that situation but I will
hand over to the interim director
and perhaps confirm
thank you
thank you chair um yeah just to confirm
so we very recently had a very in-depth
conversation with Abby Croft who are
doing an amazing job actually under the
circumstances and very much looking to
their own practices to see how much they
can manage and mitigate the situation
that they find themselves in with the
increase particularly in utilities
they're doing very well in terms of
their pre-covered and post-covered
performance they're nearly back
particularly in our area
um at pre-covered levels which is
incredibly positive and they have
identified that due to the challenges
they face that they they are potentially
predicting a shortfall next year but at
the moment they're clear that they want
to manage that within their own auspices
but we do already have a prior facility
in place for them which is a loan
facility and that is actually in place
until 2026 if they should choose to draw
down they haven't drawn down on that in
the past because they haven't needed to
and they're hoping not to need to but
they have that as their sort of backup
and they if they did find that situation
we are maintaining our current
investment and there's no reduction in
any investment towards them and we've
built a very strong partnership with
them so they're being very open with us
about the challenges they face and we're
doing what we can to support and help
them mitigate those challenges
councilor Lindsay
sorry just to apologize I looked in the
wrong place and I am
in there so I withdraw that previously
it's not I've been lumped in with
mid-suffolk that's what confused me I
was looking for somewhere in in baber
but I'm not I'm in Midsouth for some
reason
perhaps that means we should take back
what we offered you counselors
any further questions to council McLaren
in that case thank you very much
councilman McLaren for your paper thank
you
um now I would like to invite councilman
McCraw to introduce his report
paper number
cmu2 Cabinet member for customers
digital transformation and Improvement
councilman craw thank you thank you very
much chair and uh I'm very pleased to
introduce this update to members on
customers digital transformation and
Improvement uh I don't propose to read
through the entire report for Baton I
will try and summarize it and bring out
the major themes it's been a difficult
period
um in dealing with customers over the
course of the last two years we all know
the reasons why I don't need to State
them again
the moment
um this update is really to give you
information on three key strands demand
Management in our customer service
operation this is after all our front of
house
our digital platform project also our
frontal house how people can access our
services and our new corporate programs
which perhaps is a little more internal
demand management has been noticeably
affected by an increase in uh demand
seven percent uh an increase in calls 19
increase in emails and all of this has
been taking place at the time we've had
an increase in officers leaving to take
up other job opportunities within this
and other organizations
that has an impact on performance we're
aware of it we know it we've been
measuring it we measure very carefully
uh it got
unpreceptable in my view and I think in
that of many members I can assure you it
is improving and the most recent monthly
figures steadily approach our Target
time for uh
average weight and the abandon rate
we have helped to manage the demand by
exploring other opportunities to fill
the vacant positions the three
apprentices mentioned in there but in
fact there have been during this period
a constant training of new officers
particularly on in the call center
we'll be trialing this year the use of
live chat which is going to provide
people an opportunity to interact
directly during normal office opening
hours it's going to be a controlled
trial only three officers and we'll see
how that works
we're recruiting a processor Improvement
officer to increase capacity
and we now move on I think to our
digital platform project because our web
content and the ease of use of our
platform is crucial
we want to make sure that people can
find it easier to use to that extent
we've selected a partner to work with us
and in fact with other authorities in a
similar position company is called Place
Cube It's what's called a low code
platform I did ask what low code meant
a bit about it is is that we don't have
to have the high level coding abilities
necessary to crunch numbers it is there
for us it's basically a set of tools
that we can then and people who are not
necessarily trained in high level code
can use to make it work for us we can
tailor-make the whole process ourselves
we will be working as I say with that
supplier and with other users there's a
co-sharing organization going on there
um
the main priority is getting the website
replaced
to support that we have recruited 53
people within our organization to help
constantly review this as it were from a
customer Viewpoint as opposed to our
internal Viewpoint not just about to
make it easy for us to use it's about
making it easy for the customers
longer term online customer forms should
they've got to be worked on and we're
doing a lot of work on that
um all in all our key processes should
be available by the summer of this year
in terms of program management
um we're taking a very structured
approach here there's a portfolio of
programs and I will just describe them
for you each one has been assigned to
senior responsible officer and and they
are those
respect the programs are in data in
climate change efficiency and change p
people and well-being
those officers are currently in the
process of developing the briefs and
they will be taking those forward you
should expect more information during
the quarter four of this Council year so
not long to wait
I'd like to take the opportunity to
thank the entire team it is a team
operation I will mention the senior
officer Sarah Wilcox as director Sam
Lake customer Matthew Harding
particularly taking a strong lead in ICT
Brad Jones feeds into our organization
and perhaps the most recent addition
Jane Kennedy who's you've seen heard a
lot from Recently because we've been
looking at our risk management and our
strategic policy overall I believe that
the portfolio is in a good shape to move
forward not only for this year but for
future years and I'd ask you to note the
report that the final thing is to thank
the whole team and particularly the
person you speak to on the end of the
phone and the person that deals with
your query at baber thank you
to take any questions you may have
thank you councilman crawl councilor
Simon Barrett has a question thank you
very much for the report councilman
um one of the things I have a problem
with
um definition of customer is a person or
a business that buys goods or services
from another business
I wasn't unaware that we are a business
if we are
that's changed I think the wording
um
needs to be changed because they are not
customers
they do not have choices where they go
to get those Services Goods in the true
meaning of customer
it's only a technicality but I think it
probably needs looking at and I know you
would like to be accurate on these
things Alistair you're a bit picky on
these things aren't you so I think
residents
Council taxpayers or something that is
more accurately flexed than the people
that use our services
I think customers is a loose term
I think it's an incorrect term and it
definitely gives us the impression that
we're some sort of business providing a
commercial service which we're not
point
that's all I have to say is about the
terminology
thank you very much Simon um actually
this is an argument a discussion that
has been had many times from a variety
of directions now I've worked in
customer service all my life
I have direct experience face to face on
phones and all these things one of the
things that I've noticed quite obviously
is that when we put people in two
categories we say residents voters we're
not actually covering everything we are
it's an Italy
why do I think customers is the
appropriate word to use well simply
because customer-led and customer
focused organizations and we are such
tend to be a great deal more successful
than those who are merely sort of Public
Services
the customer focus is a crucial Factor
we treat
our residents our voters arm everybody
as though they were customers not
necessarily that they are customers in
the pure business sense you describe but
the fact is that this is the best way to
get the point across and I will add that
it's quite noticeable that when we have
people who've come from outside
organizations where they can direct
business customer service experience
that translates very well so I would
hold to the idea that we use the word
Customer because I think it's the
broadest sense and I think it provides
the right ethos if you like the right
culture and that I believe is an
important point about what this council
is doing we're trying to create a
culture where we treat people with a due
respect that any business would give to
anybody but particularly because they
have an impetus to do so
that would be my argument
thank you our counselor Lindsay
all right I'm making a mental note not
to do this too often but I find myself
in agreement with uh councilor Barrett
[Laughter]
um uh he probably won't like my
suggestion which I did raise this issue
when we um developed some years back
when we developed the corporate strategy
or the corporate goals which had
customer the word customer all over it
we aren't I agree we're not a business
we're here to represent citizens and
citizens should be the word that we use
because
you know the the word citizen implies
um an obligation on the part of the
citizen
as well as as on on the part of the
people that represent them the word
customer is simply a transactional thing
and and you know people said well the
customer's always right that isn't the
case if we have people ringing to
complain about something that they as a
citizen could have dealt with then
they're not right
um citizens have obligations and and
duties and
I I think that's a better better term I
I've raised this before so I thought it
was worth saying again thank you
yeah very very briefly I have worked
with organizations that provide that's
some of the best customer service in
this country
I own bank constantly comes in the top
two not because I'm a customer obviously
I've just noticed that it works and what
I'm concerned about is less about
terminology and more about effect and
making it work customers works
councilor Hinton
thank you madam chairman I'm tempted to
make a comment about customers with
people like angling water and dvla and
passport office uh who all call their
people who talk to the customers but I'm
not sure that their businesses
um while I was just going to excuse me
ask the cabinet member for digital
transformation in particular to comment
on was the fact that in these Titan
Economic Times
people are
canceling Netflix Amazon all the other
streaming services to save money and in
a lot of cases canceling their internet
connections as well are we making
provision to make sure that the
increasing number of people who don't
use the internet are actually catered
For
in terms of our customers
something with a hypothetical question I
can't possibly comment upon people's use
of streaming services and their
subscriptions all I will say is that
generally speaking when these
cancellations take place it's most
likely that the first thing they'll do
is get rid of the streaming platforms
the last thing they'll get rid of is the
actual internet provider itself there is
some development going on in the world
and a wider world to produce low-cost uh
access
it has a long way to develop because it
requires a massive amount of well some
anyway government investment but there
certainly are moves amongst the isps to
be able to provide such basic services
and we also have the fact that the
complexity the amount of data that was
available
um to most people
um
not many not everybody needs that much
data so it is perfectly possible to
produce a low-cost data provision
through the internet and through 5G
that's really not something I can
control
just very quickly if I made to the to
the cabinet member one of the key tenets
of good customer service is good
communication plain English paragraph
2.14 talks of business process
re-engineering platform Integrations
workflow capabilities
um I think all that our customers are
concerned about is that their life is
made easier so with regards to that one
paragraph 2.14 online forms
um are those forms going to be available
wholesale that all of our forms or is
that going to be a you know a period of
time and what does it actually mean
Alistair if we can ask to our customers
thank you yeah I think that's a very
good point Thank you a former Cabinet
member for the same portfolio asking a
very good question the online customer
forms need to be simpler and more
streamlined and they do not need to be
written in somewhat okay yes a little
bit of jargon in 214
uh the forms do not need to contain that
and we're working actively not to do
that plane language is going to be the
order of the day and the forms are going
to be they're designed to be easier to
use and as I say we have the shared
experience of other users of place Cube
so that we know that we can make our
digital forms easier I would give
examples oh in fact I don't know if many
people will have noticed this but if you
look at it
you can see significant Improvement in
gov dot UK over the last few years gov
dot UK used to be a small nightmare it
has become increasingly easy to use and
I think some credit should be given to
that and we are going to look along
those same lines
thank you Council Holt yeah sorry
another point in here the 2.12.2 seems
to give the excuses but the the headline
figure to me is that 24 one in four
people actually dropped out
I did not wait for the phone call to be
answered I think that's something we
should look at and I think as an
authority we should sort of hold our
heads in in shame really because that is
not good and over the four years of this
Council that has got worse and it should
not be getting worse it should be
getting better and we have to ensure
that that does get better our residents
deserve better
thoroughly agree with you and that's
what we're working on those do represent
a peak of of the performance indicators
but as I've said this is what happened
we have to deal with it and the demand
increased and the staff to deal with it
decreased it's a little bit of a problem
but it's being addressed
Council Melanie Barrett
um
hello Alistair um I'm
you you're focused on three key areas
demand management and customer service I
think we
suppose you're not
um a reference to the access points in
how you deliver face to face
services to to members of the public
um is this a sign of a desire to
downgrade face to face
um although it's so valued by so many
people
I can answer that fairly
straightforwardly the access point
provision that we have at Sudbury and at
Hadley is sufficient unto the demand it
is receiving the need is obviously there
on average we will have I think two
people present on the two days in
Sudbury and generally speaking they're
dealing with a volume of uh face-to-face
queries sometimes it's just simple
photocopying
um but sometimes it's advice the average
visit time for each of those individuals
is something like 20 minutes or less
so we're not they're not overloaded
they're not underloaded there is no
intention of changing that provision and
in fact our partnership with Suffolk
libraries is very successful indeed and
we're examining whether there are
possibilities of expanding it further
obviously that's going to depend on
there being a library in a particular
place where we have a similar demand but
no overall we think the provision is
about the right level an extra day or
extra stuff would make no difference a
day less I think would probably be a
mistake there's no intention of changing
the current setup
thank you councilman craw so no more
questions
um we'll move oh councilor Lindsay sorry
me again uh just just a couple of things
the um increase in housing calls
um seems to have been one of the key
drivers housing repair cause
and um I know it's speaking informally
to councilor Osborne about
housing issues but can we have
reassurance that something is being done
about the underlying issue of the
apparent
growing backlog of housing repair
problems that was the first question and
the second one was the
[Music]
the digital platform
um
I I'm very very suspicious of and
it always overrun
a time and cost
s and by the time you've got them they
they're sort of outdated and there's
some other whizzy bit of tech that's
come along so I just wondered if it's
Place Cube does do they have any what's
their track record have they done
similar for other councils and have you
seen seen it working with other councils
really well
and has it helped customer customers see
and now I'm using the word does it helps
citizens
um thank you
thank you very much councilor Lindsay um
I'll tackle the housing repair backlog
because of course we've all been aware
of the fact that during the pandemic a
backlog built up
um over a period of two years that
backlog takes time to work through there
is a currently a compliance issue that
is being worked through by the entire
Council led by the housing team we're
aware of that but of course once
the backlog was there
and everybody was back to more or less
normal
then the calls came in a lot of people
just you know they they knew they
couldn't get anybody to come out during
lockdown so they didn't ask now they've
been asking that is mostly applied in
2022 and it's been dealt with I think
quite successfully and we discovered
compliance issues that we're also
dealing with as far as the platform goes
um Place Cube do have a track record in
fact one of the reasons that they were
selected for the contract was that they
are supplying similar organizations as
ourselves district councils and Borough
councils across the country and one of
the features I think that's important is
that we'll not only be working with
Place Cube as a supplier but there'll be
a forum of the other users so that we
can share our common experience this is
not designed to be a um all singing all
dancing the whole point is we're not
going back to scratch we are actually
using something that's proven something
that can work because it has worked and
I think that should give us some
security I'll also add that it's
actually coming as a very reasonable
cost and in fact I think we'll see some
benefits from that in terms of the cost
of running our own services
thank you Council McCraw if there are no
further questions we'll move on to the
next item
thank you so we'll move on now to item
10. recommendations from cabinet
committee
um 10 a pay for BCA 22 28 council tax
reduction working age scheme 2023-24
I refer you to the amended
recommendations in the table papers I
would like to invite councilor Busby to
introduce this item and to move the
amended recommendations Dr Busby
okay she's come back to us again uh
you're aware that we dealt with it a few
months back a couple things have changed
we conducted the consultation
we've got reasonable response to that I
suppose but it supported our views that
option three was the right one to go for
and since then also the government have
come forward with some additional
funding which
to 25 pounds per claimant so that's why
you've got the supplement the change
just to remind you the reasons for the
decision on this is that it's to
increase the maximum reduction available
to 100 from the 95 that it currently is
and reduce the number of customers
undergoing recovery processes
to avoid unnecessary means testing and
provide Equitable access to uh
are for all customers
who receive thank you who receive
welfare benefits
to reduce the requirement for
recalculation of awards for customers on
a universal credit with fluctuating
earner earnings and to ensure that no
customer is disadvantaged on the
introduction of a new CTR scheme so I
think you'll agree that the the four
reasons for doing it uh are certainly
commendable and I would like you to
propose the
recommendations as per the supplemental
supplementary paper thank you
thank you councilor Busby can I have a
second uh Council Barrett thank you
councilor Simon Barrett sorry
right
um
oh yes yes Council Fraser can I help
yes thank you madam chairman I just
wondering if I could just ask a question
on the supplementary paragraph 1.2
for me
so the council approves the introduction
of an additional local council tax
support award for
2023-24 of up of up to at least 25
pounds
surely it's at least 25 pounds or up to
a maximum of in fact that doesn't quite
make sense to me
25 pounds
there will be an element of
funds that aren't distributed under
those 25 pounds which we then have
as it says in the recommendations that
we then have options to what to do with
that I think the intention the simplest
way would be to increase the 25 pounds
to whatever it is to to remove the
excess I mean there are a number of
other way
that's the simplest way
it doesn't quite answer your question
about an up to and
the intention is for 25 pounds possibly
a little bit more if we if we've
got okay well we'll now move on to
questions
cancers may ask as many questions as
they wish
however they must be relevant to the
subject under discussion and must be a
question
any questions
councilor Melanie Barrett thank you
um just thinking a little bit
practically
um for the recipients of this award
I have this correct They will receive a
credit or a not receive a charge
so that's brought this
coming year
yeah so in subsequent years it will go
back up to
a level of five percent or whatever
no I think the intention is that the 100
we hope 100 will remain the 25 pounds
that probably disappear
the 25 pounds is discretionary
extra benefit that we've been given by
the government just for this year
because of the cost of living I suspect
that will disappear
in this in the following year what were
they pay
well
the citizens will pay it depending upon
the the lottery customers are they but
they will pay them uh not necessarily
they'll still get 100 some people get a
hundred percent
action
what we're trying to do is to avoid the
situation what we currently have where
it's recalculated just about every week
depending upon their their income if
their income changes so their
contribution changes and by the time
we've told them what the revised figure
is they're into the next month's income
and it starts all over again so we end
up with small amounts of inner ears we
end up with the customers not knowing
exactly what it is they're due to pay
and we end up with then expensive uh
kind of trying to chase the money this
scheme we hope will be more than
self-funding
the amount that we save in
administration will more than cover the
cost to us
of implementing it in future years okay
thank you any more questions
so if there are no more questions we'll
now move on to debate
councils will only be allowed to speak
once for three minutes and this will be
timed
um would anyone like to open the debate
please
thank you
so oh come councilman crawl
thank you chair I think the only thing I
would say is that we have been through
this so many times in the course of the
last two or three months uh it's been
subject to briefings I think we should
be moving to the vote to adopt the
recommendation of being put forward and
if it hasn't already been seconded I'd
like to Second it
um it's it's a no-brainer to mine oh it
has been second and I apologize in which
case I will be voting for it because I
think we should just move straight
straight to the vote
that's my question or my debate topic
we do have a question okay councilor
Holt
something that Council advisory touch on
the castle Barrett I mean
situation costs I've harp done about
this for a number of years
every time we seem to change something
multiple letters are sent to our
residents
for 25 pounds of 10 pounds for
the full amount when they're on credit
and then another letter comes tell them
they're not owing that full of mail
something has to be done to improve the
systems that we have in place because
they're not working
cost to our residents the cost to us the
stress that we put on the elderly who do
qualify
and get a letter demanding full payment
to subsequently phone up for four
minutes 24 seconds and may get answered
or one in four may not answer
to then have the phone again and again
and again to get through to someone
who will actually possibly answer the
question who doesn't who then gets a
call back
with from someone that may answer their
question all because it's a duplication
paperwork
that's being sent to them so can we
please get it sorted it may not be you
that does it after may may not be any of
us but can someone please look into it
because it does cause stress to our
residents
yeah I certainly agree uh just
just working age
so it doesn't include pensioners and yes
the idea is to sharpen up on the
administration of it I mean it doesn't
benefit anybody does it um the way it's
being done
at the moment hopefully this will
eliminate a lot of that
councilor Osborne
thank you madam chairman can I just add
to that as the chair of the shared
Revenue partnership that's one of the
reasons for doing this because at the
moment every time with the current uh
discount that we give every time their
income changes it generates a letter
this by having 100 will prevent that
from happening so it will free up not
free up resources in the shared Revenue
partnership to focus on other things
such as the cost of living crisis that
people are going through but it will
also prevent that trigger of all that
that um each letter every time their
benefit changes
um and you're right it does I've been to
see people where they've got past and
piles of letters so that's one of the
reasons for doing this it will hopefully
prevent that from happening in a lot of
cases thank you madam
Council Osborne anymore
councilor Parker yeah I'll just I just
want to expand on that last point if I
can and I'd probably look to our offices
um because I have every every sympathy I
mean it comes comes back to again we've
got to make life simpler um for for our
residents so customers whatever you want
to call them but I rather fear
um that a lot of this paperwork that
they receive is probably from a
regulator in a statutory standpoint is
it is it not I mean what is there that
in reality can be done to tidy that up I
mean I think we should do it but
um I I presume that those letters go out
because they have to go out would that
be correct
can our officers
answer that question
certainly there is a regulatory
requirement for us to send a council tax
bill this scheme will allow us to not
repeat that process every month as
people's Universal Credit Income changes
and that's primarily where the the
average the advantage is we'll look at
income bans and if People's income stays
within that in that band then they won't
get a reassessment so they will still
get their benefit notification letters
they will still receive a council tax
bill but hopefully they'll receive one
bill at the start of the annual process
it'll have the council tax bill it will
show the council tax reduction it will
show the council tax support and it will
show if any balance
and hopefully for most of the customers
it will be that one bill for the whole
year
thank you has that answered your query
thank you
anyone else would like to
um make any comments or debate
thank you so if the
um oh Council possibly is there anything
you'd like to add sorry
nice and easy thank you
so I'll now ask the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
electronic vote
can
thank you chair that is now showing in
blue for cancers to cost the vote thank
you
councilor beer can I take your vote
please
thank you
and counselor Lindsay can I take your
vote please at four thank you
Council Creswell
thank you
Council Dawson are you having problems
as well okay yeah
thank you so that's carried thank you
so item number 10 B
j a c 21 38 half year report on Treasury
management 2022-23
I would like to invite councilor Huron
to introduce this item and to move the
recommendations in the agenda thank you
councilor Huron
foreign
thank you
good evening everybody
it'll soon be spring fellas don't um
don't worry
um better weather is coming
this is the joint treasury management
report covering the position for the
first six months of the financial year
22-23
it provides details of performance
effects of decisions taken during that
period and compliance with the council's
treasury management policy
the report explains the factors
affecting the strategy and activities
including the regulatory framework
economic conditions interest rate and
liquidity risk
the economic backdrop during the April
to September period continued to be
characterized by high oil gas and
commodity prices ongoing High inflation
and its impact on consumers cost of
living
no imminent end is in sight to the
Russia Ukraine hostilities and its
Associated impact on the supply chain
also the mini budget that wasn't really
a budget and the continued brexit
difficulties also make trading difficult
interest rates have climbed with the
bank rate increasing from three quarters
of a percent in March
of the last year to two and a quarter
percent of the end of September and it's
now risen to three percent chairman in
November with further rise probably do
at any time
more specifically for our Council
banking activities undertaken where
within the daily bank account limits
baber has reduced its debt by 7.3
million pounds
all investment activities undertaken
were in accordance with the approved
counterparty list the council's
investment activities including average
returns can be found at appendix C of
this report
the council's pooled funds excluding the
wcla have experienced a drop in
valuation but an increase in the rate of
return
compared to the same period last year
the council is compliant with the upper
limits for interest rate exposure the
interest the investment activity
undertaken for the half year was done so
in priority order of security and
liquidity over yield
as prescribed in the treasury management
policy
I think I should thank the team
well this is a bit of a hard gig at the
moment under the circumstances if you
will understand and we rely on their
expertise to get us through and take us
forward
I'm happy to take any questions on this
report and I will answer them if I can
and if not
um I will phone a friend or two friends
I have here tonight so um between us
hopefully we will get the answers Madam
chairman thank you and happy to remove
the report
thank you
thank you councilor Huron can I have a
second uh is that Council Barrett
wanting to be a seconder yeah
yeah you can do both so so you're you're
going to be the secondary yes yes just a
query you have questions on the
paperwork
um on uh 10B it says date of meeting
28th of November 2022.
on the paper
yeah so that's correct
yeah but
but
um
so what's the paper we've got then
it says data meeting 28th November our
officer is going to answer your question
so just for clarification that is the um
the existing report that went to the
Joint order and standards committee the
recommendations that you will be
considering are for Council to note we
have to formally note it
um as part of the sit for uh
Arrangements but it is the same report
exactly the same report they went to and
Joint order and standards and apologies
for the
um we should have amended the day and
put Council on the top so it's an
oversight
so I'm not mad
okay
relative term
um yeah so it's just it's slightly
confusing I think it probably need to be
clearer but thank you very much
thank you so we'll now move on to
questions
um to do with
um Bryn huron's presentation uh Council
may ask as many questions as they wish
however they must be relevant to the
subject under discussion and must be a
question
who would like to start
and everyone got councilor Busby thank
you well it's just a uh yeah uh 4.7
refers to baber's overall debt reduced
by 7.3 million which is backed up with
figures on appendix B but when you look
at Mid Suffolk it says the overall debt
increased by 8.5 million but if you look
at appendix B looks like it's reduced by
7.1 million so
just some clarification
so
do we need some clarification on this
then uh councilor Busby or are you give
or have you given that clarification
are we seeking
[Music]
yes thank you for your question I'll
take this one um yes there is an error
in that section
um 4.7 that should have stated that the
debt reduced by seven
um 7 million as shown in table three so
there is an inconsistency between table
two and table three table two was
incorrect but Table Three has the
correct borrowing figures within it
thank you
thank you for pointing that out
councilor Busby it's just to prove that
somebody read the paper
any other questions
any other questions please
thank you so if that's uh questions
finish uh we can move on to debate
uh counselors will only be allowed to
speak once for three minutes and this
will be timed would anyone like to open
the debate
so if there's no debate
um well then
oh sorry counselor Hinton thank you
[Applause]
not to refer getting confused like
councilor Barrett was in dates and
wanting in another just to say that
joint overviewed scrutiny did look at
this in on the 25th of July
2022 and we're quite happy to move we
don't move it along so uh it has been
scrutinized quite extensively
thank you councilor Hinton Council
Barrett will you
know
[Laughter]
is it did anyone else wish to say
Council bar are you trying to say
sorry
okay
um did anyone else want to raise any
points or open a debate councilor Busby
thank you yeah I think just that uh this
is obviously a report for the first six
months of the year which was seems like
a long time ago now and quite a bit has
happened since this report
and I think that's the danger of us
seeing seeing historic reports when
we're actually trying to look forward
um and I just want to emphasize that I
think it's crucial that joint audits
really grasp this for us looking forward
because
things change very quickly at the moment
and we could be caught out if we're not
careful
thank you does anyone else want to raise
any points
thank you councilor Horan is there
anything you would like to add
just yes in answer to councilor Busby's
point
when I first became chair things were
quite normal with um joint order and
standards and not much change but coming
up to four years down the line it's
become a bit of a roller coaster
and hence we do need to keep our eye on
everything and work smart it is a bit
historic but it
it used not to change much and now it
changes weekly and monthly it's it's
it's a bit of a hard gig for everybody
but um yeah we are getting that
thank you to David for his encouragement
and observation and great to know that
he did actually read the report
well to be to be honest I stopped
reading after I'd found the one thing
thank you councilor Huron
so as it is as it is a requirement of
the code of practice on Treasury
management that full Council formally
records that they have noted the
half-year position I will now ask the
corporate manager governance and Civic
office
conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair that is now showing in
blue for members to cross their vote
councilor beer can I take your vote
please thank you and councilor Lindsay
it tells me it's done it on the screen
but full I think
oh thank you Creswell have you managed
it thank you
chair that is 27 votes for
thank you so that vote is carried
item 11 paper BC 2237
Community governance reviews 2022
an updated dated report has been tabled
I would like to invite the monitoring
officer to introduce this report
thank you
Madam chairman Drew you I'd just like to
draw everyone's that counselor's
attention to um
three to eight
just to give a brief explanation as to
why you've got another report which has
another
so
just by the way of background the
district council agreed to a
district-wide community governance
review a working group was set up in
2022 and submissions of sought
those submissions actually just came in
from local Paris Council and they
submitted that they wanted a their
submission was a request to increase the
Council of numbers from nine to seven
sorry from seven to nine
and Sudbury Town Council who asked for a
boundary change now it's the boundary
change that is the issue here
um that because any boundary change
within the District Council
affected by community government view
would have the effect of
changing the boundary reviews that the
level government
they conducted
sorry yes but yeah they conducted
um
they conducted two reviews one in 2019
and one in 2021 and they brought out
some orders on the back of those now
these orders are still extent they're
still alive I haven't kicked in yet
so what that means is if you're looking
at a boundary review
or boundary extensions for in this case
sub return Council what you're going to
have to do is get consent from the
boundary commission at the end
any boundary review is meant to uh
included within 12 months that's truly
you're meant to complete it within 12
months of starting it so the proposal on
the original paper so that there would
be subject to
uh when's the conducting a further
Community review following the County
council elections in 2025 and that's
more than 12 months down the road so as
monetary officer officer decided to say
well actually Nippon review I don't
think that's the way we should be going
so we've not concluded the original
review
we still have Sudbury Town Council and
um
the other one uh North Shore Paris well
also Parish Council is being dealt with
today but
a little bit further down the road after
we've had some proper consultation and
that's really the reason for all the
underlining in that original report
um
I can't find a friend but if there are
any questions when you get to the
appropriate part
um
proposal first yeah
yeah can I have a proposal for the
report please
so yes John Ward posing and could I have
a second please
suck
um
thank you oh sorry no I need to go
sorry we'll now move to question
um councils may ask as many questions as
they wish however they must be relevant
to the subject under discussion and must
be a question councilor Owen
thank you um Subway Town Council
um
you say you're gonna look into this how
long will it be do you think that you'll
get an answer
for that
I think the first step is to go back to
the commission ask them what amount of
consultation
by them at the end
at the ends process if the commission
turn down the consent so that's the
first step and then after that I'd say
the guidance is he meant to do it within
12 months so that's quite a generous
period well well into that
um unfortunately I'm not in a position
to give you a time frame but the uh
we'll just follow due process as quickly
as possible
Council our own oh it won't be done
before May then
[Laughter]
okay
I doubt it
councilor Barrett Simon Barrett
situation with Sudbury Town Council
um
the original change in the boundaries
was to tie in with the
pre-2021 County council elections which
of those boundaries are now changed and
the and the wording I'm pretty certain
from the ground admission was that he
couldn't change until after that period
which is what you've confirmed
the the anomalies within Sudbury Town
Council where you have certain Wards
with six parish councilors and then
other Awards with one Irish councilor is
not really acceptable and it needs a
rebalancing fairly quickly and I think
my other Sudbury residents would agree
or councils would agree with that it is
really bizarre how they allocated the
seats so for example
is it fair that's the question that a
counselor in one Ward can get in with 10
votes
I think it was 10 was it 10 and the rest
of the councilors have to get about
200.
clearly not in balance
so it really does need looking at very
carefully does the montrealister think
that that is something that we can
change fairly quickly
quick question
subject to consultation
they have to put in submissions
sorry the is that the town yes
over to the Town Council
or Owen did you want to respond or are
you
content
yeah well that's what we um
that's what we um we put forward we put
forward all this so obviously waiting
foreign
consultation any other questions
councilor Busby
I'd be surprised exactly since you were
on is that you didn't suggest that
Woolsey Grange be
um hived out of sprawton uh to become
separate Parish
is that something that you would like
you discussed and considered
um well I mean to be fair I think that
very much depends on
what actually happens with all your
range as a whole because at the moment
um I can't be too sure because bullsey
grains may be extended it might not so I
didn't want to comment preemptively
before everything had actually happened
so if at a point that that does happen
and needs to go through that process
then yes of course I will consider that
thank you
and have moved on to debate would anyone
well there was a question between the
two of you so I think we'll call that
debate
so um what what we shall we now proceed
to debate and you you can each ask one
question and only up to three minutes
councilor Osborne journalsborne yeah
thank you madam just to reinforce what
councilor Barrett said
um it is absolutely crazy the way the
boundaries set out in Sudbury and is he
already alluded to you've got one Ward
where you just need 10 votes I think
there's 115 residents where other town
councilors are being asked to represent
over 2 000 residents so it is absolutely
crazy and I think when you come to
consult with the Town Council they will
be absolutely 100 up for the boundary
change because that's what they're
pushing for already so I'm really
pleased that you've in the amendment in
item three that you've changed the
recommendation so thank you for doing
that
and residents in Sudbury will be very
pleased to hear that
um a monitoring officer just wants to
clarify a matter
through you for clarification
so we've already consulted we've already
got the responses what we need to do is
consult further and that's not just with
Sudbury Town Council that's also in
Residence Etc so there are other groups
to be consulted with so I think we've
all got
as far as they respond
responsibility
so it's it's a more broader consultation
rather than just being able to go back
to the boundary commission and say well
all we did was consult simply Town
Council
yeah obviously the Town Council are
there to represent the residents that
live in Sudbury so that will be their
view as well I'm pretty 100 confident
that when you consult with residents
you'll set the same responses as you did
from the Town Council
thank you
are there any further
um does anyone want to be debate further
or have any further comments
thank you so
um
a monitoring officer unless there's
anything else you'd like to say
no in that case we'll now move on I'll
ask the corporate manager governance and
Civic office
to conduct the vote
thank you chair that is now showing in
blue for members to cast their vote
cancer beer can I take your vote
and councilman Lindsay are you able to
vote or
you're voted thank you
chair that is 27 votes for thank you
thank you so that is carried
we'll now move on to the agenda next
item is item number 12. paper BC 2238
special urgent decisions taken by
officers under delegated powers in
accordance with part two of The
Constitution
I'd like to invite the chief executive
to introduce this report thank
thank you chairman and good evening
councilors I'll be very brief you'll be
pleased to know as you know under the
Constitution where special urgent
decisions are made under delegated
powers that need to be reported back to
full Council and next available
opportunity and that's what you have
here this evening the and I'll read this
without the smoke and carbon monoxide
Amendment regulations 2022 came into
force on the 1st of October 2022 and as
part of our review of our compliance
framework we needed to make sure that we
had provision in place for the delivery
of carbon monoxide and heat and smoke
detectors within all of our Council
tenant homes that wasn't something that
we had already available under our
existing contracts so we needed to enter
into an urgent contract with a provider
to make sure that that could be put in
place by the 31st of March and so that's
what the report before you did in terms
of making sure that we could contract
that work so make sure they're completed
as soon as possible
thank you
so unless anyone has any questions that
report was just for noting
so we'll now move on to item 13.
counselor appointments are there any
changes to placings
so there are no changes so we'll now
move on to the last item on our agenda
tonight number 14 motions on notice
Channel received
thank you so we've now reached the
conclusion of our
proceedings this evening please note the
next meeting is again a Monday
so the next meeting is Monday the 20th
of February 2023 at 5 30 P.M
so look forward to seeing you then have
a good evening and the meeting is closed
thank you